House Democrats announced on Wednesday
that they would subpoena the White House
for documents related their impeachment
inquiry if they're not received by
Friday they've also asked for documents
from the State Department and president
Trump's personal lawyer Rudy Giuliani
but they warn that no one should think
they can avoid cooperation through
lengthy legal action challenging
Congress's Authority for example we are
concerned that the White House will
attempt to stonewall our investigation
much as they have stonewalled other
committees in the past it's why I say
the White House needs to understand that
any action like that that forces us to
litigate or have to consider litigation
will be considered further evidence of
obstruction of justice and of course
that was an article of impeachment
against Nixon the implications for the
White House are clear from the Democrats
don't think you can hold the impeachment
process up in the court if you don't
cooperate with the inquiry will simply
roll that in to potential articles of
impeachment as obstruction of justice
and we'll infer that the reason you're
not complying is because what the
whistleblower said initially was true
and at the White House Donald Trump once
again attacked the whistleblower who
alleged he was abusing the office of the
presidency to undermine the 20/20
elections in his interactions with the
Ukrainian president this country has to
find out who that person was because
that person's a spy in my opinion but
later in a press conference with the
Finnish president mr. Trump said he
would cooperate with House Democrats in
their inquiry
however he grew irritated as he was
asked exactly what he had been asking
the Ukrainians to do in the first place
but Biden and his son our stone called
crooked and you know it his son walks
out with millions of dollars the kid
knows nothing you know it and so do we
go ahead ask the question the question
sir was what did you want president
Solinsky to do about President Vice
President Biden and his son hunter are
you talking to me yeah it was just a
follow-up of what I just asked you sir
you ready we have the president of
Finland ask him a question I have one
for my just wanted to follow up on the
one that I asked you what did you hear
but if you
you hear me yes ask him a question and
Trump's presidential campaign released a
new advert arguing that the impeachment
process is simply the Democrats
attempting to undermine democracy
because they can't beat him at the
ballot box it's nothing short of a coup
and it must be stopped it's a message
that does seem to be resonating with
Trump's base at least the campaign is
reporting tens of thousands of new
donors and huge sums of money pouring in
sheer burton c al jazeera washington